Robin Hood 2018 because there's so many
movies called Robin Hood now so I have
to differentiate them
this one stars Taran Edgerton as Rob
because that's what they call him
throughout most of the movie as the guy
who steals from the rich and gives to
the poor and he doesn't like the Sheriff
of Nottingham played by ben mendelsohn
cuz he's a big fat jerk and Jamie Foxx
plays Little John who trains Rob and
teaches him how to be really cool with
the arrows and he gives him an outfit
that looks like it was bought at the
mall and Marian is in the film too of
course because she's the girl and she
has to be the girl this movie was
fucking bad I can't believe how bad this
film was I really didn't have much
anticipation for it so it's not that
surprising but there was also no press
screening for the film here in Cleveland
and so naturally I kind of went into
this movie dreading what could possibly
happen and I lost two hours of a
perfectly good day watching this shit I
have not been this bothered by complete
incompetence in a long time because
there really is there's really no good
decisions being made in this movie
almost every performance you know what
every performance really is not very
good Ben Mendelsohn who is playing
another villain is very OneNote as a
Sheriff of Nottingham he he yells a lot
and talks about Robin Hood you gotta
find Robin Hood he's gonna get all my
money Robin Hood
[Music]
Jamie Foxx who I usually love is really
over the top in this role and he
provides a lot of unintentional comedy
unfortunately as does a lot of the film
there's one scene where he's talking to
somebody he wants to kill and he takes
his hand he like grabs his chest really
hard and it's like oh my god I tried
really hard not to laugh in the movie
because there was a whole bunch of
people there and no one else was
laughing no one laughed during the
scenes that were supposed to be funny
either Friar Tuck pops a lot of jokes in
the movie and none of them land they're
totally off-key let's talk about Taron
Egerton who plays the lead role I liked
him quite a bit in Kingsman and
obviously he's a talented actor as are
basically everyone in this movie I mean
I've seen every single person in this
film great in other projects
Taron Egerton is not ideally cast here
I think this wasn't really the role for
him Kevin Costner or Russell Crowe even
consider Errol Flynn considerably better
Robin Hoods but this brings me to my
main issue with the film who directed
these actors was it Otto Bathurst or
Bott Hurst the director who got these
performances because everyone in this
movie is bad and everyone in this movie
is an excellent actor I don't know what
happened this is a train wreck I was
bored within 40 minutes I wanted to
leave but I watched the whole thing
right down to the ending that sets up a
sequel for some reason that if it ever
happens I'd be shocked I can't imagine
them ever making more of these at least
in this this realm they just made one
eight years ago I mean since I started
my channel in in 2009 there's been to
Robin Hood movies called Robin Hood
what's happening quit making these these
people into superheroes this is
definitely a superhero movie he runs
around and he jumps in slow motion and
he he goes really fast like Legolas and
there's 300 style editing
you know when the legend of Hercules
came out that really terrible movie and
like what was a 2014 I thought to myself
this is gonna be the last time we ever
see a 300 gladiator ripoff four years
later we have yet another one of those
movies where people run and then get
really slow and then jump and then get
really fat and then slow again like I
can't believe that's the choices that
are being made here it's it's
incomprehensible sometimes what's
happening there's so much like CGI
flying around arrows are like whizzing
by every two seconds people have like
machine gun bow and arrows like the
narration to was hilarious it opens with
Friar Tuck basically talking to us and
he's like this isn't the story you're
used to seeing I was like oh shit is
Friar Tuck talking to 2018 us maybe
they'll loop it around to make it make
sense at the end but they don't it's
just a narration the very least this
film could do is have action scenes that
we're exciting and it can't even do that
the characters are insanely dull the
plotting is just murky things are
happening in the background constantly
with the church and with the sheriff and
you don't care about any of it you don't
give a shit about anything that's going
on there's a romantic love triangle of
course because that's what we really
need in a movie like this let's talk
about Marian for a second she looks like
she's in an MTV music video for most of
this movie constantly revealing outfits
she's supposed to be in a
poverty-stricken town where everyone's
got no money and people are you know
starving but she looks like she's on the
cover of Vogue for the majority of the
film so that's great I have to be honest
if I was the studio I would have looked
at this film and said it's a loss scrap
it put it in the recycle bin right click
empty trash this version of Robin Hood
is embarrassing the costumes are
embarrassing the performances are
embarrassing the special effects holy
shit there's a green-screen sequence
with horses I loved it I loved it I
thought it was so fucking funny and
mind-blowing and again I must say like
all of these embarrassing elements I'm
positive the visual effects artist who
worked on this film are incredible at
their craft I'm positive that these
actors are all very good actors what
happened that made everything about this
movie horrible it doesn't even look good
like the color choices this grey brown
and it's just gross looking everything
about the movie I don't understand what
happened I I really don't get how so
much money can be thrown at a project
and and literally like dominoes they all
just topple in every single element of
the film is a complete failure Robin
Hood is a really bad movie but at the
same time it's really not that
surprising because none of the trailers
look good and I just really have no idea
what happened here I'm gonna give Robin
Hood and F Christ my god yeah don't
don't see this one just skip it and go
see Creed - that's a better idea have
fun guys thank you so much as always for
watching look forward to more reviews
very soon and if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]